at least 111 people have been killed in
an earthquake in Northwest China most of
the deaths were in Gansu Province While
others reported in neighboring Shanghai
the magnitude 6.2 earthquake struck late
on Monday evening rescue efforts
continued through the night to reach
people trapped in the affected Villages
where Katrina used lifeus in Beijing
just talk us through what's been
happening in the hours after this
earthquake
Katrina well emergency teams were rushed
to the area they worked all through the
night trying to rescue people from
underneath the rubble but their efforts
were hampered by several aftershocks
that took place now the epicenter of
this earthquake was Northern Gansu
Province but neighboring singhai was
also affected and this is a very arid
mountainous and remote area not easy to
access and also this is a rather
underdeveloped and poor part of China so
that really is reflected in the quality
of the construction there uh the
government says 4,000 houses were
destroyed here and there are many videos
circulating on social media showing
these collapsed buildings uh in The
Villages people fleeing onto the street
now as I mentioned the government said
they have sent emergency rescue teams
from all over the region uh to attend to
the people there but there it's really
difficult this rescue operation because
water power telecommunications have been
disrupted and adding to that is that
we're currently experiencing a freezing
winter here in northern China right now
in Gansu Province it's minus 10° C
overnight it would have been even colder
so uh uh rescue efforts are also
focusing on the thousands of people who
are now homeless having to deal with
these uh Subzero conditions and the
government has set up some tents there
uh to in order to house these people of
course these tents are no nowhere near
enough for them to to keep warm right
now the death St stands that about 111
uh 400 people around about have been
injured and the government has warned
that there could be more aftershocks of
magnitude 5.0 in the coming days so
we're talking about Thea of Gansu in
singai how how often does this kind of
thing happen in that
region well in northern China
earthquakes are not uncommon at all in
fact we had another earthquake occur in
shinjang Province uh on uh just this
morning around 10:00 a.m. local time uh
thankfully nobody was injured there
about five uh 5.5 magnitude there and
just in Gansu Province earlier this year
in October there was another minor
earthquake thankfully again nobody
injured but the last very big earthquake
to hit gunu was in 1932 and that was
quite catastrophic with about 70,000
people losing their lives and across
greater China earthquakes also are not
infrequent we had in southern Sichuan
Province last year about 100 people
killed from an earthquake there and of
course in 2008 we had another massive
7.9 mute earthquake were more than
80,000 people lost their lives Katrina
thank you very much indeed there Katrina
you talking to us from Beijing